Okay, let's begin writing code. Now, the first thing
I've done is created a new file called send_text.py. And
as you can see, this file is empty for now.
Then, if you go to Twilio's installation page, oh by
the way, this link is also available on the
instructor notes. If you scroll down on this page, you
will notice that Twilio has provided some sample code that
allows us to send text messages to our phone. Now,
I just want to run and see if this code
even works. If this program does work only then will
I try and understand how it actually sends a text
message to our phone. So, for now, all I'm going to do
is copy this code and go back to my syntax
program and paste that code. Okay, so it seems that
the code is importing Twilio. Although it is a little
different then what we have seen thus far, there is this
keyword here called from which we haven't seen
before, I will return to this later. Okay,
if you read the next two lines in the program they talk about account sid and
authorization token. Now, these must be for Twilio
to figure out who I am. Almost like
my username and password. So, let's go to
the Twilio website and figure out these two values.